right up front I use the word vagina
penis and the word copulation and the
word ejaculation and those are all
perfectly good biological words
associated with structures and behaviors
that fulfill an absolutely critical
biological role certainly there are
people who might be taken aback a little
bit surprised but I tell you once I
actually tell people that I study
genitalia and then I look at penises and
vaginas I have never had anybody say oh
my gosh you know that sounds terrible or
or be bored for any amount of time I
mean they all just want to sit there and
hear these incredible stories about how
animals actually go about the business
of having sex my name is patty Brennan
and I'm an evolutionary biologist I work
at Mount Holyoke College in the
Department of Biological Sciences I'm
interested in in a wide group of
vertebrates so we have been collecting
many animals the work I do is
essentially evolutionary morphology so I
need to be able to describe what the
genitalia
looks like rights of dissections of
animals and structures we can actually
make moles then look at the histology
just the basic architecture of the
tissue and then I need to know how they
work so I've been testing the material
properties of vaginas but because they
don't function independently then I also
need to know how the genitals function
with each other that means 3d models and
essentially use that to predict then
what are the structures that are under
selection for evolution to actually take
place and end up with this incredible
diversity of of genital structures so
yeah so these are the makeup shark and
so the males have these genitals
attached to their pelvic fins and when
the males are going to copulate they
typically use only one of these so
they'll use one clasper so the clasper
will go in the female and then once the
male is inside of the female he will
actually pull down on a muscle and
essentially open up the tip of the
clasper the tip of that is called a spur
you'll actually feel is really really
sharp and what that's going to allow him
to do is stay attached until he's able
to deliver
from suddenly the most beautiful thing I
think this is just really incredibly
cool diagrams that I find there will be
like this description of the claspers
but there's nothing at all in the vagina
essentially there's very little
consideration given to well where's this
cluster actually going and what is it
doing and so that surprised me again in
a good way because it means that I have
an interesting question to go look at so
when we have the females we can actually
make molds of the vagina essentially I
use silicon and then I inject the
silicone so it flows into all the
crevices and all the spaces of the
female we let it cure and then we pull
it out and then that gives us a 3d image
of the negative space inside of the
vagina here we have the makeup female
and she was a very large female and this
is the intestine so from here the
intestine will go up that way so that
clasper most likely is coming in from
the entrance here of the cloaca and it's
probably going right through these
little nuts right here and then once he
gets past that point then the male pulls
out on that clasper muscle to open it up
and then decried in there and just hook
itself to the female so that then he can
ejaculate and all his sperm will go up
inside of the female tract the Sharks
have this long spine Spurs in their
claspers but other animals like snakes
for example they also have spines
these are timber rattlesnakes they were
run over by cars and so I got this
locally the three-dimensional shape of
the structure where the male's hasn't
been described so we'll do that we're
about to inflate the male Hemi pain so
that they did as close as I can to their
functional shape and I'm saying Hemi
pain because of like sharks the snakes
have two penises instead of one right
and they'll use one or the other when
they're copulating
perfect this is the mold that we just
pulled out of the female we can describe
how its variable we can look at the
differences in the shapes so these are
all different species of snakes we have
a rattle snake that's the big one we
just did then we have a Plains garter
snake and then a Python and then a
yellow rat snake
we know that the vaginas needs to be
elastic because they're used also for
the babies to be born or the eggs to be
laid right but is there anything above
and beyond that that is the result of
actual copulation and interacting with
those spines we don't know whether
that's the case or not sand snakes
because he hasn't been looked at right
and so one of the things we want to do
is then look at the histology what those
tissues are in the females but also the
thickness and the relative proportion of
these tissues in all these different
species it's just this beautiful look at
that one what we can see here is lots of
smooth muscle in the red and then over
here in the blue is lots of connective
tissue then we can inflate the males
inside of the female and we all put them
in a micro CT scanner and we can get
images of where the male features end up
inside of the female and it is obviously
not exactly what happens there in
copulation but is the closes that we're
gonna get when we look at this large
vertebrates there's a lot more to
discover in the female side of things
that's going to really help us
understand then the male part of things
I mean these are these are have not
evolved in a vacuum they have co-evolved
so closely more closely than any other
structure that we can think about for me
I'm really excited about the process of
discovering and so I do actually tend to
seek out areas where there is something
that is not well understood or that we
don't have all the details
that's what happens sometimes in science
you just got to follow the questions
wherever they take you and so here I am
[Music]
you